actually actually uh drove across japan
not well not crosstalk
i drove in in hokkaido recently that was
pretty fun it was pretty relaxing
yeah it was really relaxing there was no
snow thank god oh wow but it was really
chill
it was nice i went for i drove from
toyaco
to uh what did i try hakodate like
sapporo
did you get nabori betsy hot springs ah
i did stop there but then i was like
hot in it it's kind of like nothing else
here it's like japan's
like number three is it actually it's
like one of the biggest best
hot spring resorts in japan i was i was
hungry
where's mcdonald's where's the burger
king
yeah i'll go back again you gotta go
back now
there was the go-to travel thing so i
saved a [ __ ] ton of money that's that's
insane so japan
inside of japan for domestic travelers
they were actually giving you 30 35
off your trip so hotel transportation
and then when you got to hotel they gave
you vouchers as well
yeah yeah so yeah so to spend at like
the
nearby like the towns like food so i
stayed in a place that was like
500 a night normally and it was down to
300 and it included like an eight-course
gourmet meal and it was like a private
onsen and then on top of that they're
like here's 200
to spend which you can also spend to pay
on like stuff in the hotel which i was
like
wow that's that's epic that is
sounds very familiar because we got like
dollars of vouchers or something one
night on jane across japan
and we spent it all in family mart oh
yeah that's all right yeah you can spend
it anywhere
because we like one day to spend it and
you can spend it in the same prefecture
yeah yeah yeah
because like four of us have stayed in
one hotel room what did you buy just
like a [ __ ] ton of booze and snacks
500 worth yeah there was four of us it
was like a hundred bucks worth of i just
couldn't
could you imagine something about
happening in the uk it would be [ __ ]
it would
it would be a [ __ ] frenzy if you told
people that 30 off plus get free money
to spend
the japanese government just went mental
with this and they're extending it now
as well did you see that oh god they're
extending it until like june or
something
originally it was until the end of march
right yeah but now it's until like june
july something like that which is crazy
because stuff's already
i think the stuff is pretty cheap
already here travel wise
compared to the uk i didn't realize how
much japan's economy relied on tourism
until i moved to japan and i've
i've realized how how much people like
value tourism here
like traveling i mean scary like uh in
like july
uh miyanaki went up to kyoto for our
anniversary
right and i was dead yeah it was scary
i've never seen kyoto that empty my life
and we went on a week like we went to
taisha the the thousand times yeah i've
been there yeah we were there as well
yeah on a weekend it was like a saturday
at like
1 p.m so normally i would never go there
on a weekend yeah and when i when
we went there was like four people there
yeah one yeah i went there as well as no
one that was scary
because of you telling me that yeah a
few weeks ago that i'm actually going to
kill
tomorrow oh really so i'm just going to
be walking around perfect time to film
yeah
it was actually like a ghost town all of
kyoto i can't imagine going there now
when the country opens back up like the
best experience
being like oh kyo is pretty chill isn't
it yeah no tourists no no nothing yeah
that was that was literally my
impression of it yeah and
now that i like i've seen pictures of
what kyoto is usually like and it looks
like literally my health oh it's
ridiculous i pretty much never want to
go back
like you go on a weekend or like even a
weekday it's just shoulder to shoulder
people yeah
everywhere you go because like one thing
that really turns me off going anywhere
if it's like a big tourist yeah
i hate crowds and i hate you know seeing
seeing the
seeing the tourist selfie like five
people doing the same [ __ ] poses and
the same [ __ ] selfies
yeah i'd rather just like chill out at
my [ __ ] hotel at that point
yeah well now's the perfect place to um
perfect time to go to like osaka kyoto
all those people i just like being
[ __ ] lazy like on a vacation i don't
want to go to a
museum or anything like that why do you
want to do it kyoto connor nothing
absolutely [ __ ]
i'll you know i'll i'll i'll do the
obligatory all right fine let's go and
see the [ __ ] and then
for the other days and see the [ __ ] go
and see the [ __ ] i want to watch a
travel series
with you in it it would just be i
went i went to that like the thousand
what is what is it thousand shrines
i'm like oh it's it's cool
and i'm like when am i where are we
eating though
me and connor are exactly the same in
that size because yeah like
is it like when you go on a trip with
someone yeah and they bring out a
schedule
i'm just like oh girl no no no tell me
the restaurants we're going to
what are they specializing and also how
are we going to have at least four meals
a day if not i'm gonna have a problem
because when i travel i want four meals
a day
like i'm just gonna eat eat eat like i
don't i'm just an absolutely but you can
do that and also
clean the meals you can go it's
stressful it's stressful like i want i
wanna go to a place and i just wanna
have
no pressure to go anywhere yeah if i
want to go see something i will go see
something but like if
if i feel like i'm pressured into going
somewhere that just
automatically makes me not want to go
somewhere unless it's a this is a nice
restaurant also it's like it's vacation
right i don't want to [ __ ] work
you know i i'd work walking places
wow going to see the shrine would you
ever consider being a tour guide for
your viewers for the right price
sure chris i'll i'll i'll wait for the
right price
i don't mind i mean doing the oh i can
we can't talk about that yet okay
all right was the trash taste special
that that was a nice view that we had i
could appreciate that but then also at
the same time it's like this is fun for
10 seconds
but then what are we eating yeah well i
mean let's be real like
like we probably would have not gone
there if it wasn't for to be fair
yeah i i don't like for me when i go to
a place i don't remember what i saw what
i did i remember what i ate
is that is that is why is that that's
not weird that's not weird
i mean i i i don't remember what i did
in hokkaido but i remember the meals
like vivid vividly i'm i'm kind of the
opposite i had a big
fat crab and they murdered that crab in
front of me and it was delicious i i'm
actually no christian added to the
flavor
as much as like you know i love the food
like especially like hokkaido you know
wherever i am and
you know especially anywhere you go in
japan the food's always going to be good
but i don't know like i'm always kind of
the one who was like yes i remember
going here here here i'm more of a
location person than a food person
i'll just see like a tourist thing pop
up and i i went nervous but [ __ ]
well maybe that's maybe that's the
problem you're kind of going into it
with like a negative mentality right now
i just want to eat
like what what is what is so special
about this place like i i
i think i grew up with it because any
time my parents would take me to this
place we'd like take
take the tourist picture oh my god yeah
my parents when we do that yeah and i'm
just like i don't [ __ ] care i just
want to read my hotel room and play my
[ __ ] game boy yeah yeah
sometimes you just want to chill in the
hotel room and just like get some food
and watch
this [ __ ] just like don't like traveling
no i love travelling
but i hate doing tourist stuff being
in a new place i just don't like
actively going to i like the environment
like a new environment i don't give a
[ __ ] about like sports hot spots i want
to meet i want to meet people
have i like chat drink and just eat and
chill i want to do something active yeah
something active to me like going to a
place and taking pictures is not like
an active thing that i enjoy like if
there's like an activity there
or something i could do then yeah great
i'll [ __ ] go well it's weird for me
because
i like i i don't go to the locations to
take photos if anything i very rarely
take photos at tourist locations because
i feel that
by taking a photo of something it's like
the only thing you're going to remember
is what's in the photo whereas like i
want to rem i want to actually remember
right there then rather
this time i'm there for a week no plan
is it vacation are you filming
kind of half and half like i'm doing a
documentary on old
uh dilapidated kyoto houses that have
been redone and
whatnot that'd be really nice but like
really no plan
maybe just walk around and see what i
can kind of find yeah also i like the
feeling of discovery as well i like
going somewhere and
not knowing what i'm gonna see if it's
like if it's all planned
and you know people have like researched
this place and i'm like i know a really
cool place because i've read up right
about and everything
it feels less special than just like
driving around and seeing a cool place
and just being like
that sounds that looks cool you're
absolutely right like i
my um cousin came over last year to
kyoto we had like one day and we
literally just got in a taxi i was like
oh the king gakusha you go doesn't fish
me an aria we'll just do it went to all
these like five places it was all right
he saw everything got the photos but it
wasn't really any good
memories or experiences yeah as a result
well i mean i i don't like
whenever i go somewhere i'm not the one
to be like all right
these are all the tourist locations
let's go here like i'm still very like
picky choosy on where i want to go
yeah because because to me it feels like
playing an open world game where you
have all
like the checkpoints like marked out
already well i like a breath of the wild
kind of
experience where i'm just like exploring
that place yeah i mean you do get that
in kyoto though like kyoto you really do
yeah like a video game you can discover
little shrines little restaurants oh
there's so many
coffee shops there's so many cool well
well especially with kyoto i actually if
anything i avoid taking the trains
anyway
we always walk from one location to
another because
the walk along the way is where you find
all the cool [ __ ] yeah and then on top
of that you get to go to a tourist
destination so it's like
best of both worlds in my opinion
absolutely yeah like for me my my
ultimate
holiday or my ultimate tourist sport is
just put me in like a cool place and
just don't tell me anything about that
place and just
right let me just get a samsung
[ __ ] it was so hot in kyoto i remember
sweating my ass off though well when's
it awful it was summer
like july or something yeah we went
there too it was gonna die
i did not like that did not like
japanese summer it was
as bad as everyone said it was going to
be but i thought everyone was
exaggerating
because like there's no way it can be
that awful but it was no it's pretty bad